if I can't hug thank you
the Barden Bella is an unlikely group of
not men who somehow managed to win it
something that didn't have to do with
baking I can hear you
they've graduated college at spread
their wings are attempting to fly defy
of lousy life with a shout of white
privilege
hopefully not becoming the failures we
all expect them to be so really good
about where I'm at right now I was
trying to get into bed school
fingers crossed ah where are they now
my name is fat Amy Winehouse so let's
get cracking
I quit my job you want fun I know I quit
it's fine
oh come on it was an overreaction I
would do anything to sing with you guys
again Eddie did you guys ever hear the
u.s. focus on this performance to put
the troops in Europe what if I could get
us an invite
yeah I've suddenly got a bunch of free
time so yeah
sighs we've never competed against fans
but actually have instruments so what's
the plan coming up on the neck oh you
guys just sing other people's songs like
karaoke Carrie oh that's so cute
calamity this is serenity Brasserie and
charity I joined yogurt I could be
obesity another day on stage for the
Bellas this is their big plummet their
fade out into nothingness sure Reza have
I ever let you down all the time for
your very unreliable it's like one of
the hallmarks of your personality you're
not remembering all the times I've been
awesome
my parka finished
I love you I submerged
[Music]
try to have some dignity
yeah well we don't do anything with
Dignity okay they really do need to join
the workforce yeah
you